the good Gene indicators symmetrical
face muscularity the highest is sex
appeal does he look sexy it's right
there looks matter 0.28 physically
attractive e-taper broad shoulders
narrow waist and the absolute last one
which you'd think would be higher is
intelligence the next category was good
investment ability indicators older than
self-expressed in years chicks dig older
guys after that tied for second was good
earning capacity below that next is
favorable social status and then last is
ambition and industriousness next after
this we're in the hypothesized good
parenting indicators the highest score
is desire for home and children below
that is emotional stability and maturity
beneath that is raising children well
with Goal priorities and right at the
very bottom is being kind and
understanding so here's the next section
hypothesize good partner indicators
being a loving partner 0.14 is devotion
and right at the very bottom loyalty